allez c'est parti regardez la prochaine
vidéo salut ba ba voila je fais appel à
toi parce que on est dans une situation
difficile ma femme et moi et
malheureusement avons trois enfants ma
femme elle est tombée malade un dernière
et pour payer tous ces soins
malheureusement n'a dû vendre la plupart
de nos affaires mais bleu voiture une
vraie galère quoi et le pire dans tout
ça c'est que moi je n'aime pas en voyage
je la rivale plus quoi qu'il arrive elle
plus j'amène pas voyage le faux pas de
bijoux parce qu'on peut plus dans notre
situation le permet plus quoi
et donc voilà je rappelle à toi pour
peut-être que plus la régal et à ma
femme voilà je vais demander je vais
demander à marion julien oriana et
gabriel qui sont deux publics de bien
vouloir venir me rejoindre
les signer
venez mes amours venez près noir estimé
giri ça va mon chéri ça va merci d'être
là mère au chaud merci pour la vidéo
merci mon chéri alors marion tu peux
prendre le micro machines il faut que tu
saches que ton mari thème très très très
très fort j'en doutais pas mais là je
suis vous êtes une famille magnifique
des enrochements vous êtes magnifique
j'ai cru comprendre que depuis la
découverte de ta maladie les temps sont
très dur pour vous ouais jamin détente
demi solde en fait en tout cas sache que
tu es magnifique ceci merci
pendant les deux je vous dis tous les
quatre vous êtes très très beau will
fait heureux de vous avoir avec nous ce
soir alors financièrement ça devient de
plus en plus difficile pour vous bien
sûr et aussi pour toute la famille ce
soir on a décidé de vous faire jouer à
la corde de noël il ya une corde ici et
je vais vous bander les yeux
à chacun et vous allez avoir une vision
pratiquement nulle puisque vous allez
avoir la vision de base à 4 je vais vous
mettre ce bandeau sur les yeux vous
allez devoir suivre le chemin de la
corde et au bout de cette corde il y
aura quelque chose peut-être que ce sera
un cadeau
peut-être que ce sera matthieu delormeau
est-ce que vous êtes prêts aux jouets à
jouer avec nous à l'accord de noël oui
avec les enfants également
oui voilà
attention voilà regardez vous allez
allez voir les petits casta voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la dame s'est pas comment tu fais alors
je vais le demander
je vous demander de prendre la corde qui
veut prendre la corde qui veut qui veut
prendre la corde et vous allez suivre
tous les deux vous avez les yeux de la
maison d'izieu attention tenez vous
est-ce que vous tenez
tenez vous et tiens ma chérie tu as
besoin de ton frère et vous allez suivre
la corde d'accord donnez moi votre micro
il faut vous prenez la corde comme
ceux-ci d'accord et vous suivez l'accord
un accord attention vous y aller tous
ensemble et à les y aller et gabriel
bien et vont devoir rejoindre avec les
yeux de quelque chose c'est pas de
regarder les temps glisse c'est pas
évident ils m'ont suivons la corde
continuez continuez à la ola on voit
très bien que ma vie en fait si les
pieds et bien oui très bien très bien et
petit se débrouille très bien
continuation vers la corde ya joseph qui
les aident en plus un bon jour attention
c'est magnifique quelques jeux dakar
dak'art espère bien fait passer une
photo attention donc les petits sprints
poteau dans quelques instants peut-être
qu'on aura une salle et pis pour eux
je vous rappelle qu'ils habitent à
marseille c'est vrai qu'ils ont des très
grosses difficultés
suite à ce qu'ils auraient arriver
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont envie de passer
un bon noël
attention ça arrive peut-être au bout de
la corde mais en plus vous faites vous
visitez un petit peu les locaux sont pas
liés au halal à la voile attendait la
top top
allez petit shut up j'aimerais qu'on
arrête donc la famille j'aimerais
maintenant qu'on leur enlève les
bandeaux merci joseph
on va leur enlever les yeux de benjamin
castaldi c'est sympa de minutes humain
très vite suivi vous avez retiré votre
bandeau et maintenant je vais demander à
julien marion oriana et gabriel julien
qui nous envoyer un message de prendre
tous les quatre la corde
tous les quatre
je vous demande et à trois de tirer la
corde on va tous contents sens
haha de3 tirée par les voyages on voit
partir
bah oui mais ce quota vol tout gagné
cette voiture venant partir l'ancienne
avec cette voiture
[Applaudissements]
m
vous gagnez la voiture les chéris
c'était pour vous on essaie l'air voilà
ça va vous aider mine de rien dans votre
vie qu on a offert de série en achetant
on offre une voiture maintenant ils sont
trop mignons les uns dans les heroes
vous laisse dans votre voiture déchiré l
état vous allez repartir à mater et
merci kershaw footer nous avoir offert
cette voiture c'est vrai qu'on voulait
absolument leur offrir